imagine waking up on the beach before
dawn the glimmer of light leads you to
the shoreline suddenly a wave pulls you
in
at first you use the direction of the
waves to guide you but once you're in
the open sea with powerful currents of
barding you and very little light how
can you be sure of where you are and
where you're going for a hatchling sea
turtle
the answer is magnetoreception that's
the ability to sense magnetic fields we
know many animals use this sixth sense
for navigation what we don't know is
exactly how magnetoreception points
here's what we do know earth itself is
like a giant magnet the motion from its
liquid outer core generates a magnetic
field certain animals can sense this
field and use it as a compass to tell
them if they're heading in the right
direction
and a map to give them signposts along
the way there's two competing theories
for how magnetoreception works one is a
chemical sensor the other is is a
mechanical sensor the first theory is
that animals have tiny magnetite
particles in their bodies that act as
magnetic receptors magnetite is the most
magnetic natural metal on earth it's
been found in many animals that exhibit
magnetoreception and it's thought that
it's the only potential sensor that
would be sensitive enough to captured
these incredibly tiny variations in
magnetic field strength that would allow
the animal to to not just know whether
they're going north or south along the
magnetic field line but know the precise
beach that they need to get to the other
theory is that animals possess a protein
in their eyes called cryptochrome which
allows them to see magnetic fields
cryptochrome has been found in the eyes
of several migratory birds but we
haven't proven either theory for a few
reasons
with magnetoreception you don't know
where to look magnetic fields pass
invisibly through the entire body so
researchers don't know exactly where
these magnetite
articles are cryptochromes would be
attached to particular cells I mean so
mistakes are made all the time and so
far cryptochrome experiments have only
yielded positive results in the presence
of magnetic fields much stronger than
Earth's the frontier is now soon not so
much at the animal behavior level but
actually getting inside the brains of
these animals and trying to find these
sensing cells and connecting them to the
neural circuitry it's not so much of a
question of which animals have this
sense but which don't so researchers
have said why not humans maybe we had
this sense at one point deep in our
evolutionary past and and lost it but
maybe there's a vestige left researchers
in California and and Japan and have
gone after this this holy grail one more
time with a very specialized experiment
one that relies on double blinding and
magnetic shielding and they're seeing
glimmers maybe even more than glimmers
of this magnetic sense in humans it's
starting to be reproducible and they're
really excited about it